sommes dans la chambre du roy dans
laquelle se trouvent de très beaux
plafonds peints qui ont été réalisées à
la demande des mares de prix le
propriétaire du château de montpoupon à
cette époque qui revient des guerres
d'italie
[Musique]
il revient très influencé par cette
architecture et par la peinture la
sculpture le renouveau de cette
renaissance italienne
et il va demander à des artistes
italiens de peindre ces plafonds
donc là on est bien sûr une
caractéristique de plafonds peints de
cette époque renaissance puisque ce qui
va différencier des plafonds moyenâgeux
c'est que ceux ci sont entièrement peint
et couleurs très lumineuse très gai
cette époque on espionne couleur blanche
un bleu blanc et rouge sur les couleurs
personnel de françois 1er qu'il prend en
souvenir de son par le duc de la
rochefoucauld
les matériaux utilisés à l'époque sont
principalement des pigments naturels
pour donner cette colorisation et le
lion était souvent fait à base donc de
peau de peau de lapin
avant dernière poutre c'est la seule à
être travaillés comme ça à l'intérieur
sur le côté les motifs on les retrouve
nulle part ailleurs il ya comme celle là
alors pourquoi est ce que c'est
l'artiste a voulu faire sa petite touche
personnelle est ce que c'est sa
signature ne sais pas j'avais remarqué
et c'est grâce à vous et merci beaucoup
revenez souvent c'est long mais ces
lancements
[Musique]